Robert: I work at a small lobbying firm downtown,
about two blocks from the White House. Basically
what I do is I do a lot of research for the
senior staff and write up memos. It's very
hands-on experience. While you may find yourself
occasionally making a cup of coffee, you're
also probably going to committee hearings
up the hill or you're doing actual research
that senior staff will then use to bring in
business. You really get to see the fruits
of your labor in your internship in D.C.
You should do Hillsdale WHIP because it's
such a great opportunity to get both great
work experience for your resume, but also
great academic experience. As someone who
did the freshman courses of western heritage
and great books, the great stuff that Hillsdale's
all about, to then come back out here to WHIP
and take the statesmanship with Dr. Spalding
or history of the Cold War with Dr. Moreno,
I really fell in love with Hillsdale College.
That's something that WHIP does for people.